[Music]
from chicago and all over the country
the newly vaccinated are hoping to hit
the open road this summer
and if you need a new or used car brace
yourself for a bit of sticker shock
you see a worldwide shortage of one type
of computer chip
is wreaking havoc on the automotive
supply chain
and this is happening just as demand is
increasing
the result record high prices for new
and used cars
and tough choices down the road to some
degree
it looks like maybe i'm going out of
business any other year stephen wade
would be worried to see his 40 acres of
car dealership space in utah
so empty instead he's overjoyed
i've had the best year of my history in
my whole life
i've had the best year financially and
how many years have you been doing this
look at this great hair i've been doing
this all my life
wade's lucky cards are all thanks to an
ongoing shortage of computer chips
you see it's been more than a century
since cars were just four stiff wheels
and a chassis
the first chevrolet to offer wireless
apple carplay
and android auto now they're luxurious
comfort machines
infused with top technology but the
semiconductor chips underlying that
convenience
are also key to computers and wireless
devices
for which demand shut up dramatically
during the pandemic
right now it is a big problem cisco
chairman and ceo chuck robbins
this week semiconductor is going
virtually everything and what happened
is when when kova
hit i think everyone thought that the
demand side was going to
to decline significantly and in fact we
saw the opposite
global car makers have been forced to
pause or reduce production
ford's f-150 and chevy trailblazer are
among dozens of popular brands impacted
we generally see uptick in sales
starting in may and then going
uh july is another big month and then
august jessica caldwell examines
consumer trends for edmonds and says
this shortage
means you're likely to make concessions
on your next car
particularly the f-150 because they sell
so many there are so many different ways
you can configure that vehicle
and in times in which you have to scale
back you can't necessarily offer
everything to consumer wade says when it
comes to chevy silverados
he usually has around 75 to offer
right now he only has four and of all
the cars you see on his lots
half are already sold by the time they
arrive
so car buyers he warns should expect a
different experience
this summer so you're saying be patient
be flexible
and be willing to dig a little deeper
with a little bit of patience and
understanding we can all work together
so the system works
and it can work for the customer and it
could work for the dealer
now look current predictions are this
shortage could last the rest of the year
possibly into 2022
wade says there is one small silver
lining for customers you can now get
more bang for your buck
on a trade-in they're apparently being
valued at a premium by as much as
20 but at the same time you're less
likely to get a deal on a purchase
because demand is so high and supply is
low so then it evens out i think i'm
glad i bought a car
last year i'll start with that and then
also patience does not work well sadly
for a lot of people especially on a car
dealership you know it's like if you if
you need to get out and get back on the
road
how long can you win and here's the
thing this situation is only getting
worse
exactly the worst is yet to come when it
comes to the cars and the chip shortages
and because of that supply chain issue
you know president biden signed an
executive order to look into this in
february it will be a long time before
the u.s can
catch up and you could have a crunch
come the holiday season for computer
devices as well great story